esta política puede convertirse en la
primera mujer jefa de gobierno en la
historia de la República italiana con 45
años Georgia meloni lidera una coalición
derechista encabezada por su partido
fratelli de Italia o hermanos de Italia
las primeras palabras del himno nacional
es importante entender que si se nos
Llama a liderar este país lo haremos por
todos lo haremos por todos los italianos
lo haremos con el objetivo de unificar a
este pueblo para subrayar lo que lo une
en lugar de lo que lo divide 10 saltaré
lo divide no es un improvisada en el
mundo de la política a edades tempranas
formó parte del movimiento social
italiano o msi creado por Seguidores del
dictador fascista Benito Mussolini en
1946 según su autobiografía en este
grupo encontró a su verdadera familia en
sus años de juventud había declarado
creo que Mussolini fue un buen político
es decir que todo lo que hizo fue por
Italia y la República Italia pero
recientemente se distancia de esas
palabras que elevaban al Aliado del nazi
adolf Hitler ganó su primera elección a
los 21 años una década después se
convertía en la ministra más joven de su
país fue la encargada de la cartera de
juventud en la administración de Silvio
veracrusconi es madre de una niña de 5
años su discurso está basado en la
familia tradicional
quiero que nuestras familias tengan
hijos quiero que no sean un bien de lujo
quiero que las mujeres no tengan que
elegir entre ser madres o trabajar No
quiero que las mujeres sean objeto de
discriminación salarial quiero Jardines
de infancia gratis
romana criada en un distrito de clase
trabajadora es hija de una madre soltera
su padre las abandonó al nacer melón y
compara su movimiento con el partido
republicano de Estados Unidos exalta El
Patriotismo y rechaza las élites el
apoyo a su figura llegó en el contexto
de unas elecciones con baja
participación y tras la inestabilidad
del saliente de gobierno de Mario draghi